those echoes to give one but it's
remarkable the passion I the new
he gets it to you whatever you wanted
yeah baby give you
so you can catch and finish you never
have to put the ball on the floor
let's check in with Andre Bob takes a
lot in coffee cheese Marcus
is it Andre I don't see all of the Hawks
games but I think tre young passes hero
with his left hand as his right hand and
when you get that type of comment from
someone up Marcus Johnson stature that
really lets you know what other culture
scene
that hit you though
Johnson's I've ever played against a
something he was
at six seven
to break down any defense so if you get
a compliment or bark this is big market
just had his number eight retired at
Milwaukee a week or so ago I get to see
that the rafters why they flare anyway
Oh tea on the line here Brown this
[Applause]
shot the bomb
but thinking truthful one they'll have a
second tray going in puts it mo verse
murder de Collins John will drive at
bouncing prey trapped underneath
move to the corner flips it
[Applause]
so walking
[Applause]
Milwaukee traded using that tricky W
Jeffrey himself up get stuck it on the
baseline well the initial defense of
dick was pretty darn good because Trey
had nowhere to go down on that box but
to his credit I have to play alive
but absolutely I mean you're absolutely
right but it's the tricky driven by him
to get it out just swing it around on
there is John Colin gives it back to
Trey nowhere to go you get a bigger guy
you then Fraser switches on them on the
baseline that's a pretty easy floater
there 16 assists for Trey to go without
ten points but Fraser gave up the
baseline and that's a no-no and Trey
young delivers the clutch shot
maybe that's the game-winner
the Bucks have the ball was 6.6 left in
overtime up 34 we know it but 144 is
both of these teams fought hard really
gave themselves a chance to win here but
the Hogs have a chance with the stop to
walk out with a very big win over a good
team well 267 points have been stored at
this game and the fans are yelling
defense 6.6 to play in OT
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
George Hill
lays it in good hands five pepperidge
brown kids away puts it up
he goes up by one
Oh
initially great defensive every nearly
cooked it away from it but Brown
recovered and takes it to the glass he's
got 27 and the pucks go up 135 to 134
this is just a determined play here
almost gets the steal but he goes right
to the rim I mean this is a physical
shooting guard here Brown this goes hard
at the rim which he's been doing all
night long and febri trying to catch up
with the play from behind and the Bucks
take the lead at 135 to 134 sterling
Brown with 27 points he's at five threes
at this one we'll travel to Texas
tomorrow join you Tuesday night from San
Antonio when the Hawks take out the
Spurs pregame coverage of hawks live
begins at 8:00 Eastern Time at 8:30 tip
on the front end of a back-to-back -
State Farm arena
on Wednesday night to beat Philadelphia
well the Hawks have one more crack at it
here right and win the game in overtime
both clubs have used their timeouts
[Applause]
bucks come out and deployed defensively
Hawks have a chance to get a shot off
and if there is a non-shooting foul the
Hawks will go to the line
Milwaukee over the limit
Hawks brought them floor Kevin herder
the man to get him in and Tony Brown
repentant reminding DJ Wilson he cannot
come over that line crowd standing
burger gets it in Kevin looking log to
the basket poked away
[Applause]
[Music]
take that beat the clock
36 to 135
Plus to play three ends up with the
basketball
[Applause]
after the video review
[Applause]
got it to his right hand beats the
buzzer and then after two bounces three
it falls in and at land
Winston in overtime the basket